l'environnement on en parle beaucoup
désormais avec la promotion des énergies
renouvelables et cette expérience
étonnante menée sur le toit d'un
immeuble du pas-de-calais une éolienne
horizontale l'engin va fournir
l'électricité nécessaire aux parties
communes franck genauzeau patrick the
storm
contrairement aux apparences ceci n'est
pas un ustensile de cuisine géant mais
une éolienne horizontale la première de
ce type installé en france
le site a été choisi pour son exposition
au vent explications ben c'est simple en
fait le vent arrive sur les pales sur
ces six pales de chaque côté les deux
rotors sont solidaires et vu le profil
et l'incidence de dpal sur le rotor en
fait ça tourne et sa lola on entraîne un
générateur qui va nous envoyer du
courant en bas du bâtiment installé sur
le toit d'un immeuble
l'éolienne fournir à très bientôt
l'électricité des parties communes
discrète elle est plutôt bien accueillie
par les habitants
on la voit seulement vers que des plats
chauds sinon les biens elle est bien
troquer mais je trouve c'est bien mais
ça aussi fait des tempêtes savoir
qu'elle peut pas tenir
je sais pas si ça c'est pas un petit peu
d'argent c'est bien 1000 euros par an
soit 25 euros par famille les économies
sur les charges sont dérisoires par
rapport à l'investissement 70000 euros
onéreuse mais pratique l'éolienne
horizontale pourraient se multiplier sur
les toits de la région on espère pouvoir
renouveler l'expérience non plus en
expérimentation mais cette fois en sites
de production sur d'autres immeubles sur
des immeubles existence sur les
immeubles le nouveau encore quelques
réglages
l'éolienne livrera ses premiers
kilowatts heure elle aura alors un an
pour faire ses preuves et pour se
montrer à la hauteur de ses grande
cousine verticale